if I apply a force to the globe I can
actually get it spinning in roughly the
same way that the Earth spins but it is
it is tricky there's very little
friction on the bottom because of it
being supported on this thin layer of
water you can see the more force I apply
to it the more it accelerates so we're
getting it speeding up here
when you push that like it's not too
easy to get it going
why is that friction probably so strange
why is it not really easy to push what
is it about this giant speed that makes
it a challenge to push the weight the
resistance what happened to gravity it's
really heavy too so I'm pretty sure the
weight of it sitting down so making it
tough to you don't think it's weight is
supported by that water well I know it's
supported but even though it's supported
down moving it's still like if it's
center of gravity's here we still have
to push the weight coming out from here
so it's pretty heavy I'm pretty sure
most people will say if you just apply a
force to it it starts moving that's not
really the point I want to make the
point I want to make is the more force
you apply to it the more it speeds up
more gets going faster and faster and
faster but it's got two and a half
tonnes of inertia so you can really feel
that you have to push hard to accelerate
it what do you feel when you push on it
just moves when you push something it
moves does it do something more than
move spinning it's rotation velocity
speed this some word you're looking for
there is a word I'm looking for
what do you feel is that hard oh not
really
it's easy going very fast though it's
not like hard to push but it's sort of
hard to get room fast is it hard to make
a fence why is that right to make it
fast can we try let's try let's get it
going really fast ah
hey how's that rotating oh pretty no
clothes moving how do you make it go
faster um mutti me push hard hard hard
and more harder and dad you put a force
on an object a net force an unbalanced
force and it it come on goes going
really scientific without it goes you
studied physics right yeah which means
I'm probably looking a little bit like a
[ __ ] oh yeah that's okay no it's easy
to push but like if you try to go fast
then it just sort of stays same speed
but could you bring it to a stop
probably not definitely not can you give
it a shot good stop for water okay other
than cheating yeah what do you think not
gonna happen
yeah Wow back into you can do it huh I
don't think it's gonna work well we give
a shot kinda what do you see that it
stopped but it only stopped because it's
on like a very soft thing of water
pretty much I'm pretty sure so it's not
going to stay stopped or what it
shouldn't huh all right are you playing
a force to this fear here
yes what happens when you apply a force
of the Spirit then it changes like speed
that's pretty awesome observation you've
just made yeah
do you know that I guess so we could
generalize we could say force causes
change in speed man you were nailing
this can you give me a high five
boom what do you think physics is Oh
like how things work I guess and you
want to know how things work yeah how
old are you 11
you seem pretty smart for being 11 hey
do people tell you that you're smart no
you think you're smart no I think you're
smart okay you take my word for it okay
really yeah I guess